you know hello and good morning let's
get started first words I speak today
that's always a little bit tricky so
let's get rolling with some games of
blitz I got a request to play um games
blitz games still that are a little bit
longer and why not try that out yeah
there's something like five plus three I
will I will go for that in a moment just
before I do that I wanted to point out
it's a really excellent cover artwork
then I now got by Willem yeah William TM
is responsible for this very nice cover
artwork so if you want to check him out
here you got the name to Google thanks a
lot again for giving me this really
great picture and I like that a lot
so let's get started with some games I'm
trying this 5+3 I don't know I never
tried that I have no clue if I get any
opponents with this time control
actually let me instead of doing the
quick one let me do it customer
for some reason I ever set a rating
range is always limited to 2900 I mean I
don't think there are many 3,000 players
that would play me but it's a bit odd so
we have like 5 let's say 5 plus 2 or
something
we have real-time standard rated let's
get rolling ok let's see if I get some
opposition there I have no clue I never
tried that if I'm waiting for a long
time I'm going to scrap the IDM don't
want to sit there for a minute until the
game is actually starting
I got a question um in the latest video
what tea I am drinking or what my
favorite tears um my favorite is
probably the chilling but I drink all
kinds of team also like green tea but
what I'm currently drinking them and
pretty much all the time is I had a
pretty bad cold like two weeks ago if
you watch the the free preview of the
Magnus fight fight like Magnus course
you will see or hear this very clearly
because I had a I could barely speak I
really had to work out on this um in any
case I had a cold and I am got them
advice to drink ginger tea so take fresh
ginger and put it into hot water and
then you've got ginger tea and that
really helped quite a bit
and I really liked it so I'm sticking
with this so like one big mark of ginger
tea every morning and that is the tea
I'm drinking during there was recording
sessions no it seems like nothing
happening with him so I have to do
something different it's kind of what I
expected so let's try we can try a 5-0
maybe this is better this is indeed
better I'm getting a game so let's do
five zero for a change I think it's
essentially this is the same as 3 plus 2
in terms of game length and in
comparison I would prefer 3 plus 2
because you don't get the silly stuff at
the end so it looks like we get a slash
neck off and let's see what line
McMaster Lee is going for going form the
traditional Bishop g5 main line in
recent years there has been a shift - or
recent here there's been a shift - 795
so let's do this
my experience is that this is more
frequently played in online blitz
then the bishop takes f6g takes of six
line the really super sharp lines they
get less frequently played this you see
a bit more often okay now yeah this is
not so precise because I want to go to
g5 and now I get to do this in one move
it is more precise for why to start with
g3 and only later play h5 okay it's not
like white is playing terribly bad chess
or anything but it's a bit more precise
to not play h5 so a couple of things
that I can do but should be six as the
most normal-looking move and I will go
for that
Kame yeah here here I have more than one
good way to play I can play Bishop takes
c3 as a simple one or 97
mmm stuff it's a tough call actually
there is also the move before which is
entirely different but interesting
because I mean he has neglected
development quite a bit let's go before
I probably should have calculated this a
bit longer but
I kind of think it's time to open the
position up yeah this is not really
something that crossed my mind because
it looks some it looks like a little bit
too much
some do we take it I guess we do take
first
yes simply Bishop f6 looks good I wonder
if I can do more if I can take on c3
already
hmm it looks actually very interesting
at students if he just recaptures I
cannot be unhappy about that yeah going
Bishop f6 attack the song directly look
at the pawn and if it takes the bishop
which is obviously critical I will take
B to rook be one Queen g5 and that
should give me enormous compensation
with all kinds of things on the plate
Bishop takes d5 Quincy 395 there are
many things that Wright has to defend
against you know what I forgot about
he's got bloody Knight f6 check so silly
I totally forgot this
okay I can take this however and this is
still interesting because as a
threatened Queen g3 here and like BTX
queen g3 check king mukla this is still
a very very shaky stuff for white it was
not my intention to to play like that it
was more more blunder than anything else
I overlooked again if he takes that
Knight f6 checkers killing me okay so
here well
I got I got 95 and
possibly night deform
can also take beat you first
currently the pawn is taking away a
pretty important flight square
so 94 is probably Queen f6
don't know exactly how and if I take the
five wait wait wait wait if I take the
five he has to check with the pawn
Knight takes as Queen d2 made so bishop
d5 pawn takes and then they Arkansas
fantastic I don't need to continue him
to calculate
because he's got just no temper move
like he takes it I play 94 and that is
basically game over
you
still pretty slow from I mean I'm not a
very quick calculator anyway but I
really feel sluggish early in the
morning
even more
then then usual
let's check this I can just take b2 here
there's nothing I don't need to do
anything fancy I think
look chicks
you
you know now how does he
YUM so what now
me check what is what is a simplest way
to do this taking F - it takes G Phi F
that isn't so great
Queeny five is kind of the lazy move and
I don't have to set that much time left
so I'm going to do it this is also just
having night c2 coming
you
so just 9c2 em maybe that I think I
should have a mate but I don't see it so
I'm just going to take all the material
I still have to keep in mind that it's
increment so again an increment game I
know if I have 10 seconds on the clock
and I'm look up that I'm going to win
but that's not the case here necessarily
yeah I think right just overextended far
too much in this game we just quickly
switch on the analysis like him I think
here the best move was probably g3 and
after g3 black plays Bishop g7 and the
thing is later if white goes h5 and he
should do that sooner or later for
example he could do that right here then
black is going to play Bishop f6 g5
later
so I basically got granted um Tempe here
with h5 so I went to g5 and now yeah
before it's okay that the engine says
before is a good move so I'm glad to
learn that I certainly can just play 97
and continue to fight for the square on
d5 but before looks like the most
energetic and now event complete berserk
with f4 which I cannot quite believe so
engine gives takes takes and now wants
to check on h4 but now now it shows that
B takes c3 is also strong so takes and
now white um yeah F takes Queen takes
and yeah computer already says that's
winning from luck I kind of thought it
should be the case but you never never
completely sure in such a short time
control yeah so I have this idea this is
hanging of course and yeah many things
just don't work out like something like
this it's just going to going to be a
disaster yes God
white all over the place him and you
cannot hold this I'm attacking with
everything and the king is wide open
so here Bishop takes this is the winner
it took me too long actually to figure
it out 94 in f2 Luke takes rook g1 and
25 is even the strongest move okay now
Knight c2 is made in nine moves okay I
didn't see that one but I'm just winning
the house the rook is hanging and
everything is falling with a check okay
so let's go back to the actual
start here so that was a 5-0 let's go go
for another 5-0
kind of we can mix add a little bit with
three - I think I'm comfortable three -
I would I would play five plus three but
it seems to be difficult to get
hmm even problems getting a 5-0 it seems
that maybe I actually let me do it like
that
not sure if this is a difference
technically
uh-huh okay quite a game against Doc's
get another Sicilian okay
can pre move that but I get a Ross limo
yeah this is a line with Queen c7 that
Magnus has played quite a bit over the
last year and also the one that I
suggested to play in my repertoire Black
has a pretty wide choice against the
Rasul emo and this is I think always
good to good to know that you have some
flexibility in your in your opening it's
not dependent on ya a single variation
let's say okay you will probably go f4
here
it's an interesting way to play this
night h5 something that looks good here
on I don't know you can also just play
Bishop e6 in this position
just develop Knight h5 is interesting
however
can also take I'm not quite sure about
this
you
one thing here to take note of is that
ee if he will Castle queenside which I
expect to happen okay I was wrong I was
wrong I would have quest that queenside
then okay here
I don't know B should be 6 but stupor
should be 6 are we afraid of Bishop e5
or something no so let's just get this
out
I currently cannot Castle kingside
it's um
it's a bit of a problem
[Music]
you
yeah you know here I actually wonder if
I can Castle queenside in this position
it looks it looks a bit odd but I have
this g5g for business here that is
interesting
it would be a different story if he
wouldn't have played Age 3 which of
course is perfectly normal at the spot
where he played it but just from a
structural sense if the point is on h2 I
have no real attacking idea here but the
soul g4 so g5 g4 yeah so I can paint him
sometimes forget due to the platform
switches um yeah so I can actually open
up the G file here let makes this
castling queenside a little bit more
interesting because normally this would
be too risky
yeah what might try to open up the
queenside quickly and it's a bit of an
airy King position here so this this
seems like a playable option for me I
could be wrong but it seems like
something that can be done I wonder if
there should be 5 or sometimes an idea
that doesn't really threaten much
it seems to be a little bit stunned by
by castling queenside
let's see what happens it's five zero so
the club
difference met us a little bit more I
really think that in the increment time
controls you can sometimes accept to be
a little bit down if the quality of the
position is compensating for it so yeah
let's go d5 that was the idea okay but
now this is killing his own piece so I
don't mind this too much yes he has this
nighty for stuff but
pilot is relevant
we think of this think about this for a
moment
you
I can go ninety-eight yeah that is
[Music]
that is possible
so that after night you
96 I can give up the exchange on the six
that would definitely be some kind of
compensation I think
you
okay
you
so let's the king should be a little bit
more save them and after 96 I'm just
giving up the exchange
a pretty good Bishop pal
if you got the bishop and a pawn for the
exchange it's usually completely okay if
the bishops are strong and I think the
bishops on g7 and e6 actually more than
strong they are pretty much fantastic
so now I'm basically telling him okay to
do it do it Jack please
so my bishops are pretty good the
question is can I do something concrete
with this or is this just like a
nice-looking position but not really
convertible let's say into something
concrete going to push this up the board
if I played the Bishop to f6 oh that's
an interesting take on this so um yeah
yeah let's do it okay it's not this is a
difficult decision and I have to now
make it quickly and now I get to to take
the default pawn or isolate the d4 pawn
for a very good position but that wasn't
a clear
clear-cut decision really if this is
good or not
I'm not even sure if this was right
notice this was wrong because now I get
to take the d5 pawn
so we should before he wants to give the
exchange back then okay
okay I can I can go c4 here also
okay I'm doing this in different
different way I play rookie form and
then we should deform
okay so a check now
if it takes the 41 first
maybe you can play that
didn't do it
and the question is do I go rookie 3 or
do a trade or or what
and let's go rookie 3 I think I'm
getting the d5 pawn anyway
yeah he returns returns that song
go here
so I'm upon up at the end of all this
all this check check check
chick
and now he's got the check on a form
how do we do this I don't know
I probably can check them
I should not run into a self-made right
that wouldn't be too good
[Music]
I'm pretty much capable of doing stuff
like that like find a cute way to get
checkmated
I don't see it I don't really don't see
it relevant
okay
you
so let's just go up
five seconds that is helping
oh I actually blended the Queen in one
move okay I mean I saw that he has four
seconds and I will win
so I didn't I didn't didn't really
compute anymore I just made him move
medicine he at the end there was
interesting him all interesting I'm I'm
not completely certain how I should play
this like after you 595 looks completely
normal but maybe it's not not the best
what I think is however after 98-94 king
b7 like a three just go to a two to one
one key point a three is really much
disliked by the engine um engine wants
to go rook e1 but I just want to get to
the point I think actually it is a
mistake to play 96 and the engine agrees
that is good computer wants to play rook
81 and says why this better in this
position that is possible just keep this
idea in a position but don't play it
immediately that could be actually a bit
better because now I'm not so sure sure
how I can sacrifice the exchange in the
first place after Knight takes Knight 66
like the the rook is on the Queen so I
would probably have to play a somewhat
move now after 96 I'm perfectly fine
so I'm just curious what the computer
says yeah it gives 0 in this position
initially at a pretty shallow depth and
now it gives white some advantage okay
interesting I didn't expect that
like 0.3 0.4 when it's given but I mean
here the compensation should be pretty
clear that I've got something for the
exchange I'm really surprised that the
engine is giving white an advantage in
the first place because I really don't
see why this should be the case even if
you just do it in a very abstract way
let's say I put this bishop on e6 yeah
just just one single isolated point how
is he ever using a rook the e-file is
blocked you cannot trade off the e6
bishop and the two bishops have a pretty
significant
significant range I don't know I I
thought black should be fine I mean 0.3
or something is not terrible for me him
engine evaluation but I actually thought
that would be kind of kind of equal okay
so we're going form another five zero
game pretty much somehow I think him I'm
winning pretty good rating on those on
those games him
now let's go deform
you
in my keep it simple default
is almost a primo if you only have to do
something else after c5 after everything
else I would play g3 almost this is not
a bad move actually he b6 Prague played
pretty rarely even by players who play
the Queens and yen I think they are
probably afraid of Bishop g5 because
after Bishop g5 you have a bit of a
limited choice against the torii attack
so we're going to transpose into some
sort of Catalan Queen's Indian hybrid
going to take him so no this is the very
well-known pawn structure hanging pawns
almost not yet but almost c5 will happen
a lot probably not immediately that
would be extremely risky
which is just a euphemism for bad
honesty I expect there should be seven
to happen Bishop d6 looks odd
I think an ID b5 is a pretty bit of a
problem against the smooth maybe he
wants to prepare this somehow
should be for Wow
it's it's also a bit of a strange one
like never really wants to check on c3
okay I'm going Queen b3 I don't want to
going to get into a huge time
disadvantage early on
so I have both moves look good actually
let's take with the Queen again this is
five zero and I have to make sure that
I'm not falling too far behind on the
clock I cannot rely on the increment and
I have to
if to really take that into account that
I don't get any
additional time so here my idea is to
get b5 in and if I do blacks position
would be strategically pretty dubious
because then see 795 I forget this and
see 795 will be permanent weaknesses so
he's stopping this going a form
my bishop on c1 looks bad but it is
pretty much I mean at some point this
will open up it's really it is going to
happen and then my bishop will become
becomes stronger again here what do we
do aged six maybe wants to go on
courtesy want to do f5 or something
G five or is that just like a
it'll improve a little move might be
mmm-hmm they're just surprising
I mean c5 is not playable as b7 is
hanging see preparing this may mean
seems to be yeah okay I thought a five
now is a good move
five I'm certainly certainly better
1964 that was that was early for sloppy
Oh Kim
[Music]
there was a bit sloppy actually
you
now that I played a play to spell him I
miss played that I did not really read
it did not really register that he had
this Knight d6 c4 I was always thinking
about like b5 and and then play Knight
be 64 I did not
Wow doesn't even want to have any c5
opportunity
that is surprising
Kate we go book a AIDS maybe
you
you
now I again like my position
think I'm hugely better or anything like
that but
would assume that
Vantage
okay Jake
good to cheek and I guess maybe
you
try to enter the position with Queen a
tool
seven I can just play
you
you
yeah Queen d7 probably he wants to well
then I can take and go e-form then I
have an addenda definitely have an
advantage here
this looks like a strong move actually
he wants to go Bishop age three I guess
maybe d4 okay some let me check
you
and now maybe this one queen f8 looking
at the pawn so that Bishop h3
seems to be prevented
No
you
nice to me you could drop him I think
he's playing this quite well
now the queen is set to to enter so I
probably have to go here
hmm Oh
I completely did not see this move
coming
you
uh-huh and that looks bad
[Music]
you
you
like Quincy - or something is is really
really really dangerous
really terrible position you Wow now I
completely miss play dad
okay now I have an idea on my own
this threatens mate
Queeny tomb
what did I handed him
I'm going to get mated him
Queenie to something like that and it's
also strong but a magic made
I have to see six idea sometimes okay
have to take this kind of
have to do that's to take with the Queen
of course and then I homemade it's made
it one ah that that was bad that was
really bad okay I'm going to go for the
rematch but I will look at this game
data because I want to learn what I did
wrong I have some ideas what was wrong
but I want to want to check it with the
computer because I add on at the
beginning I was definitely in very good
shape and then I'm completely screwed up
[Music]
this a sick PA 65 is one of the good
lines against this so-called Jabara
opening
a six is another good line
that is the one that I had in my names
Oh
what goes in repertoire that a6b five is
less known to people so I this is what I
often play in blitz you see why its
position is a little bit odd here but
she can go 93 and then develop
the goals of Plex play is to gain a lot
of space on the queenside so that
White's potential queenside castling is
completely out of the picture
interesting it tries to connect to the
c5 square and I mean try is wrong at him
he will do it him very likely Knight b3
or 93 coming I need to get c5 in so I am
went 97 a5 is a strategically a pretty
normal move trying to isolate my before
porn from the rest of the confirmation
but he has to always watch the porn on a
5
can be a liability
you
I'm thinking Bishop d7 b5 here maybe to
get rid of this e to Bishop and if he
takes it then indeed a five pawn would
be like if he ever should be five takes
takes now if I now go be should be five
he can capture and play Knight to c6
is
not a problem
[Music]
attractive
okay
there that looks odd but I want to okay
not now things change a little bit what
I wanted to do was Bishop d6 and put
some pressure on the night
now this is a bit different
if I go night be seven by the way move
that I didn't actually see beforehand
can I just pick up the a five-point
more or less yes
why he has a Queenie one that is a very
strange-looking move but maybe he's got
that just attacking before
yeah it's a bit strange but could work
so if I take a five now night takes
before
[Music]
I have to play Bishop b5 here actually
this is that this is a good move
there should be five and now I take and
take a five right
he has a bit of compensation then for
schwa
when c6 square is a liability
and he immediately goes for this even
though I'm not really certain it is a an
issue because at the end of the day
the remaining the remaining structure
looks pretty okay
so let's say just rooks the age
you
how do I get how do I get the pawn the
a5 pawn
I also wouldn't mind to trade those
nights
you
maybe it's Godric a for in-store
you
okay
I can go a night see for maybe 95 maybe
doesn't even work
okay 95 he goes 95
you
rooks III and then what
I can go 95 then
you
okay
now 95
I also have a five year
sure that this helps
McKenna's let's do this first
you
Wow
that I didn't even consider in the least
bit
five we can take
okay let's do this getting a bit short
of time him
you
you
you
you
it takes takes bishop before we give too
seven and then rook c2 back it's really
strange
- he's got night before I guess
not before it's going to happen anyway
you
my back rank is unfortunately pretty
weak
this is why I cannot play 95
you
you
you
and that is a super quick quick porn
I have 12 seconds of God
just lost anyway because of the time
okay he wanted to change two games
against me where I felt I didn't
understand the position properly because
that gives let's say Here I am I don't
think this can be bad for black that
would be surprising so the computer
gives 0.3 or something who wide but
shouldn't I be able to get something
against that porn let's say and so on so
I'm fairly certain I I miss something
something good not like we know
something that I should not be in
trouble I think if I'm doing this right
so
engine once 98 and disposition yeah I
mean this felt a little bit shaky Luxy
forward
you
you
Jim f3 if all that's pretty remarkable
[Music]
Bishop g3 also was interesting just
going for Bishop b1 here you hear the
kitty the engine gives right already a
substantial advantage after a bitter
thought of the engine before has given
us the best move
you
you
[Music]
yeah I don't know what exactly what
exactly did I do wrong here
Rocsi fire
she fires firmly
at the beginning where things go go a
little bit wrong
ninety-eight
six is remarkable
it makes a lot of sense yeah once you
think about it a little bit
it covers before very safely and looks
at a five so I'm at the same time
putting a bit of pressure against his
porn and I'm covering mine so this is
definitely a point I'd like to check the
game before I'm Micek I think I have to
go
and is that's a way I that I know that I
can that I can use so if we check this
again I cannot request the computer
analysis doesn't seem to work um yeah so
this must be pretty okay right and I
mean I know one thing that I did wrong
that that sets fairly sure so I'm this
is a position where white should be
better yeah to some degree it's just
like I'm I'm always on this pawn and
it's a just a standard structural
advantage a five is actually liked by
the engine
with exactly the game continuation so it
takes takes and I also thought that okay
and also thought that this must be good
yeah yeah it's one point something okay
this is what I thought but then I play
it played it badly I really played it
badly
so rook e8 it seems fine and now we are
getting no we're getting there I guess
YUM
I allowed Bishop f5 maybe here I have to
just play more prophylactically mayor in
a blitz game sometimes just cannot find
them
say this is this moment off of real
thinking
the ultimately managed to invade on the
light squares and and of course my light
squares are weakened so the thing is can
I prevent it what the engine is
suggesting here is of course pretty
interesting like this and now Queen D 3
which is just preventing this activation
Dam
[Music]
it was also problematic in the game that
all the rooks got traded off that that
was not very helpful
[Music]
this must be must be a somewhat bed of
it the thing is said in the game even
here it sure looks quite good
but once we had this it's really not
easy at all because my my Bishop on c5
is a good piece to keep everything let's
say together covers before e3 and so on
but can never take anything so it is a
purely protective piece and my bishop on
g2 cannot enter his position at all and
I cannot open the position at all the
computer is not already on zero and the
thing is it's not so easy to find a
constructive plan the engine suggestion
of playing a quick Age 3 and maybe G
form yeah it looks very sensible so what
I should do is I I have to play in a way
look at s7 it's just terrible I have to
play Queen a to keep the rook on and try
to play this and there's some somehow
then you might still have some kind of
initiative but even the trade of one
rook helped black pretty pretty
[Music]
pretty substantially
that's difficult very difficult the
moment we got here I felt that things
are slipping and then I just I played
one or two silly moves and then what got
killed maybe if I'm now getting so yeah
yeah I'm here I'm already losing almost
the engine already sees that it's
invasion time on the light squares then
the best according to the comp is to go
back and defend
which
yeah and this is absolutely terrible to
play for a human player we can he can
attack on the light squares which are
severely weakened and and then f then I
pretty much fell apart you're here here
things are pretty grim no that was
I was nicely done Quincy 2 is good move
and this is also strong and Bishop f3 is
also the strongest move and here the
maiden 1 which I overlooked but it's
already cannot you cannot defend it
anymore so yeah very very nicely played
by black so what's going on let's go
here and like one more game maybe let's
do a three plus two at the end why I
always like to do it like that somehow I
have a clearer idea what I'm doing if I
see all the setup also the rating ranges
you
you
nope takes a moment that seems 5+2 is
easier to get
come on
era was very costly and those two losses
another service record
you
after night a three-year black has the
extra option to go f5 but I'm not sure
that this is actually better than going
b5 and this additional theoretical work
lowered does not seem very efficient for
me to learn so I'm just advising to
transpose
this line is fairly sharp
g3 I'm not really such a fan of because
I think this is good
I'm Bishop f5 is the right move
sometimes difficult to recall all the
lines
the main okay
interesting
the main thread she was f3 the move
before and now we went night before
you
okay so how are we going to play it the
knight on c6 is hanging
it's tough to move it away
yeah oops what's going on here
in touch into a driver support great
that's a good moment to get this so I
was getting to the point where I think I
have to take it now um what is best now
the exchange is not really
I'm not really worried let's aim about
the exchange
I just wonder
let's do it's trickier I thought efore
could be an idea threatening f3
I'm just unsure what happens if he takes
on a form
it's probably good YUM we need for now
it should be fine even doubt like in the
sveshnikov it's really often the thing
even doubt try to play as actively as
possible
okay if one cannot be taken I'm actually
Wow
what
really
okay so let's go f3
you
so do I want to check on g5 that's a
good question I guess
yeah I think many things here are pretty
strong actually
can also go a five
Queen b6 is also strong move okay let's
go Queen b6 just a tech f2
you
maybe Queen d2 495
yeah
you
so let's
this runnin
yeah dude do I want to cover it right
I mean on 26
I would have before next pretty much
regardless
Bishop age six is also surprisingly
just claiming that their three-point is
worth a lot
huh that time is getting low
someone's take
it is still a pin so
have to yet tape
so I'm actually then able to take
yeah I would do this now before he goes
King D to
and now I can actually cover it when one
group the end
let's let's cover this for the moment
you
Oh
maybe I'm too slow with what I'm doing
him
you
you
but I only have 40 seconds which is
or prompts me to play a bit quicker
you
you
you
that's me I don't really
right how can we do this like here sorry
I am sorry heaven sorry is the wrong
word I'm basically saying sorry to
myself yeah that I haven't done this
before
now opening up the queenside going to
take route a three
okay so invasion time
25 seconds this is the main thing
position is I think pretty good not sure
how good but
just rupiah oneness kind of a problem
and check there first yes
you
so okay
going to have a winning position with 19
seconds is going to be a big obstacle
seconds and I really should stop playing
with with without increment it's always
unnerved me that you have this silly
games
are you kind of
was actually already over in some way
and then we recognize own six seconds
that's not good
you
now you have to just wait a little bit
longer
decent game without a stone-age time
control
you
mm-hm okay yeah I mean that was just the
game word which was pretty early on
terrible for white weekend the opening
play was pretty bad like him he I'm
already clearly better and after he
allows f3 it's I think strategically
lost disposition like minus three but I
didn't convert it really well I mean
this is a game where he shouldn't see
move 30 and he he did and he shouldn't
um it's it's obviously completely
overwhelming so yeah II don't think it
did it too badly wishes to note that
just too slow I mean here it's not minus
three but it's like minus one point
something Jim this is just a very bad
position and um yeah okay this is the
thing that you win pretty easily even
with the one second increment but
without one it's just um it's just bad
if your time management sucks I thought
um in particular I thought too long
around here where the choices are
actually pretty clear and you should
just joke that just - out the moves and
take one of the good positions I have
them I still have a bit of tea left so I
can go
I said a 3+2 game No
and right
it was a 5-0 game no they didn't resign
this right even know I had no increment
you
you
so let's get formed let's go for one
more game I lost three in a row
not exactly necessary losses anyway
Johnny duck I'm down to 470 arcades and
I just just stopped to play those time
controls that I dislike anyway just for
the sake of getting a quicker game
in particular form
in particular for them
or the live commentary games increment
is absolutely ideal because you get to
play the games out yeah you don't have
this silly I know - out quick moves try
to win on time all those cities stuff
you just don't have that and in general
I think this is something that just for
the instructional value is some is
welcome
[Music]
how is he not taking only for now
yeah we have a sort of a closed Katalin
where blacks um peace placement is odd
to say the least
mm interesting interesting here's Bishop
f4
and Kim but it's not really
and this has a team
[Music]
I try that you prevent him from playing
c-65 this is what
strategic Amos I can't even do with this
95
cannot take I'm probably not threatening
night X is six though that is probably
just
well if it's my move I could take it and
I would okay so you just
okay I'm statistically lost I'm happy
happy about that anyway let's see how to
actually punish him down so let's go
yeah I think I should go back up f-for
doesn't even try to play c5 okay
now I'm a couple of good things you can
go before
rook d6 is a move
I'm going Rock d6
you
now is he somehow
play with ePHI if this is the only thing
that is somewhat
concern
to use a pin then rook against
against the Queen
I would like to play before it's a good
tempo move
before
six
and it's still kind of alive in this
position
maybehe I am
you
if five
three night is
spoon
you
be fear before
just about surviving this
yes hive only move
you
what did I do wrong
I really don't know
you
what did I do wrong I have no clue I
mean
you
game should have been over by now really
but it isn't just isn't
Queen d6 a tick and then take on c5
you
okay I can check first if I go if I
check No
mates it's okay now take care first we
cannot take it because of a mage
backlink mate
and next move is the check
yeah unless he goes to d8 then I take
the seven porn immediately
get to winning ending with still I must
have done something terrible because the
game should be over much earlier
you
not sure here sure have you if they hear
the sound maybe you're not because the
microphone is pretty it's pretty good
down but you don't
some of the noises
it's a it's a Wednesday and it's always
the day when the apartment above me I
think is clean
which is sometimes a bit noisy
okay
didn't see that at all
you
so
you
Wow didn't expect to get that far with
the pawn so check
or s7 let's go s7
[Music]
ain't
that should be end of game
okay
you
okay no not to rematch let me let me
sorry about that
but I just want to have a quick look
there why I screwed it up because the
moment he takes on e5 the game is
essentially over strategically but I
couldn't nail it
I just couldn't nail it the the thing is
he's got this incredibly weak Square I
have the pressure he's got hard time to
play c5 that should add up to basically
a win but I didn't manage so I think
actually probably around here is where
I'm doing doing the weird things
yeah Queenie of three years is a lot
stronger than Queen III and maybe not a
lot but
you
three
is very strong because
I am this is an additional issue so that
if he goes here I have b5 and he can
never take because of this ischium yeah
and TL Kim
okay the computer is still giving me a
huge advantage maybe I'm keeping a huge
advantage I just felt yeah it's always
like plus one
I just thought I should have had much
more but computer actually approves of
my play now now I ever I should not play
rook b1 but Luke d1
huh
okay it's covers this I mean sorry it
covers the d6 pawn and now I'm attacking
c5 and e5 I did not actually register
that d5 is attacked
okay so that was better than lucrative
one a lot better actually and here you
should not take on the six which is
probably losing here that losers
you should play King f8 yeah okay then
I'm still substantially better there but
I kind of expected to have more which
was probably not a proper assessment
so Queen f3 is a lot stronger though the
idea to play b4 b5 is just wrong in the
game the issue was that like here if I
go before I can go a to a6 and this is
not not that convincing I mean I can
play let's say a three but she goes c5
and while this is still nice it's not
it's not devastating
nice is so very nice okay I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching
and yeah very likely I'll do one
tomorrow again bye bye
you